both issues that i've mentioned both uh
this monorail which is menstrual pain
and this peleonia painful intercourse
uh affect hundreds of millions of women
and are both real unmet needs there are
no dedicated treatments that the i would
say western
industry
has has
provided them
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homer adventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking about female tech meet the
otamahod the ceo and co-founder of
gynica a medical company at the
forefront of therapeutic cannabis
research and development in the field of
women's health previously autumn was the
ceo and co-founder of lumiere lab a
global leading cannabis research and
development laboratory aimed to provide
evidence-based cannabis solutions both
companies are subsidiaries of asana bio
group a holding company specializing in
scientific advancements in the field of
cannabis which utam serves as its ceo
yo tom hold welcome to 20 minute leaders
i have a feeling this episode is going
to have some really really interesting
conversations how are you today
i'm very well michael how about yourself
today
i'm doing well and i'm a little confused
i have to say you tom i have to
understand
how does one get to work on cannabis
products
for women's health well i mean i i'd say
it's an amazing i think it's an amazing
opportunity and there's probably a lot
of innovation to be doing there and it's
a remarkable thing to work on but
it's it's still a little confusing
for to be for me to be speaking to a
young male entrepreneur working on this
startup i
completely understand where you're
coming from and what's behind
these questions i live it for the past
uh
almost five years
and i have to follow these questions and
um there are some very good basis to it
and the fact is that i'm uh
in a way i'm a black sheep in a doctor's
family uh probably not the first
but uh as such
uh
i always found the intersection of uh
business and medicine um
very appealing
and um since a very young age
growing up with i would say medical
terminology
around me
and understanding the needs the gaps
some of the different aspects that
involve
you know the
next generation
of
medical
practice
i found myself very
attracted
by
the business side of of medicine and
that led me to my first job
after my military service
working for a medical conference
organizer starting off as a
as an
assistant producer and
climbing up uh all the way to uh lead
for a certain period uh the sales
department raising millions of dollars
for medical conferences from
pharmaceutical companies
um but around 2016
um beginning of 2016 i found myself
uh
reading more and more and actually being
pulled by mentally
by an emerging field called the medical
cannabis space
and realized that uh here in israel
there's uh
apparently and i i didn't know that uh
before
but apparently israel is the
global leader in cannabis research uh
moreover the most uh no
we were elite right you realize there
were some initiatives
indeed so so uh
what's behind it the fact is that thc
actually was discovered in israel
uh in the early sixties by professor
rafael
uh indeed and there's uh there you know
there's a
funny anecdote about that i've
had already uh quite a few lectures that
i've heard from uh professor micholem
he's still working by the way arriving
to the university the hebrew university
every day he's 92 years old and he is
considered to be the founding father of
cannabis research and the story is that
cannabis is actually
an illegal
substance moreover according to the un61
convention
cannabis uh simply is a dangerous drug
uh and
you know israel and we won't be
surprised but uh professor rafael
michoud i'm from the hebrew university
heard about this you know notoriously
known
uh
substance called hashish
back in the 60s here in israel
and
he heard about different
i would say appealing
effects that are caused by it and as a
chemist he
approached one of his friends at the
police station
who ran one of the police
stations in the center of israel and he
asked if he could borrow some of the
confiscated hash by the police in order
to study what's inside of it because
again purely from a scientific point of
view he was very interested about what's
behind it
and
funny enough he found himself coming
back from the police station with five
kilograms of hash
to the university
and this is how thc was discovered
globally not here in israel
this is uh considered to be the
discovery of the first
active ingredient in cannabis called thc
which is the
notoriously known substance uh
which is psychoactive more
moreover actually psychotropic there's a
slight difference between
psychoactive and psychotropic we won't
get into it but
this was actually a groundbreaking
discovery because as i mentioned it's
illegal but only in israel i guess you
can call your friend
in the police station and ask for such a
favor
and no one else globally had any access
to such substances
and uh this was actually a door opener
that allowed uh
for 50 years of research in academy here
in israel
which is unheard of
because cannabis is yet
well known by the un as an illegal
substance
so
there are
quite uh i would say difficult and
challenging regulatory hurdles
that still are uh
a challenge for the medical cannabis
space and the cannabis industry as a
whole
um but this
early 60s discovery actually opened the
door for us in israel to become a global
leader and to gain experience of 50
years of real research comparing to
other countries where it was simply
illegal
um followed by uh the discovery here
back in 1992
of uh the endocannabinoid system which
was the second major discovery here in
israel it was discovered by professor
lumir hanush who's actually sits on our
advisory board
and he
served as the right hand of professor
mashulam
for many years in the hebrew university
and they are considered to be the
forefront of cannabis research globally
and
this is just a tiny brief about
why israel is considered a global leader
in cannabis research and it's not just
it's not just a cliche it really is the
case because the fact that uh
dozens of researchers
have
worked throughout their years in academy
in such departments actually um
throughout the years it was only the
hebrew university later on the the
technion joined and other universities
as well but this fact comparing to
any other country for many years that it
was simply illegal
brought
israeli researchers to really lead the
way
in everything to do with cannabis
science
unbelievable so i can obviously through
your
deep understanding and excitement to
this field i can i can understand that
the kind of the cannabis side of the
venture but but i'm still a little
puzzled by the by the gynecological side
of the venture
absolutely so there's definitely a
strong basis to it as well but i'll
start off with with where i began and
the fact is that uh
i started my journey in the cannabis
space after taking a course at the
technion
in 2016. it was actually the second
entrepreneurship in cannabis course it
was a first of its kind uh i would say
academic uh
course that allowed to get a taste of
pretty much every vertical and angle of
the cannabis space
just you know as an anecdote today is
around the 25th class of this course or
so um but this course actually
opened my eyes to the realization that
uh first of all israel has such a unique
value proposition for the world for this
emerging
cannabis industry
evol evolving but
moreover i realized that the biggest gap
that there is currently globally is the
fact that we simply don't know enough
about cannabis and moreover in order to
know enough we need to research it but
because of the regulatory hurdles
that quite limit the ability to research
it's
it's very narrow and especially six
years ago it didn't change much until
today
but this realization that research and
development is key for acceptance of
both regulators the medical community
the scientific community the patients
most of all uh
the only way to bring comfort
credibility safety is by bringing
research and development and proper
i would say scientific
manners
to uh such a
such an emer emerging field and with
this in mind i truly fell in love with
with the space and with this field but
you know it was a nice thing to say that
this is what i want to do with the rest
of my life
but i needed to to find something that's
more solid and um
you know funny enough
back then because there's a lot of
misinformation
and this information with everything to
do with cannabis um
i found myself although i'm not a
scientist i have a ba in business
administration uh i always had a
business orientation but uh i found
myself i found myself reading scientific
papers about cannabis because this was
the only i would say credible source for
uh
for for knowledge about cannabis
and one day a certain paper caught my
eye
after reading
that the female reproductive system
is actually the organ with most
endocannabinoids in our body after the
brain
the female reproductive system is the
organ with most endocannabinoids in our
brain in our bodies after the brain that
means that when we speak about
endocannabinoids those are receptors
that actually bind to the active
ingredients in cannabis called
cannabinoids and actually when we
consume uh we look at it as a
as a
key and a whole to the key meaning once
we already have those receptors but once
we use cannabis we are able to trigger
them and activate those receptors and
those receptors are the one responsible
for the therapeutic effect
that's
spoken about with cannabis and
surprisingly we realized that the female
reproductive system is the organ with
most of those endocannabinoids after our
brain
and this added up to the fact that as i
mentioned earlier i'm uh you know come
from a
a doctor's family as a black sheep in a
way
and my father is a gynecologist and you
know things that are quite i would say
taboo
uh in our world were not a taboo for us
you know on shabbat dinner or just on a
on a daily basis speaking about
menstruation about sex about bleeding
about pregnancy uh about such issues was
not uh i would say it was not something
uh that was hidden under the the rug for
us
and i think that this is one of the
things that allowed me to realize that
the field of women's health is quite
unaddressed
and uh
in the past few years i've learned it
more and more actually and i
unfortunately i realize
uh
how much
i'm i'm sorry to say that they have been
neglected
uh by the medical community by the
scientific community by the industry
um with the most basic issues and
ailments that women are suffering from
that still are
unmet needs real unmet needs i mean when
we speak about
painful menstruation
we speak about 800 million
women worldwide every days
who are going through their
periods
and
generally speaking
some of them
are have to
you know
be in bed for a day or two every month
uh or when we speak about uh this period
which is painful intercourse uh around
40 of women suffer from painful
intercourse throughout their life cycle
and both both issues that i've mentioned
both uh this monorail which is menstrual
pain and this ballerina painful
intercourse
uh affect hundreds of millions of women
and are both real unmet needs there are
no dedicated treatments that the i would
say western uh
industry uh
has has uh
provided them
so even when you speak about menstrual
pain currently what what women are using
is tylenol is other under uh pain
reliefers but there's nothing targeted
dedicated
uh locally
um
and this is very sad you know
let's be honest there is uh viagra in
the market uh
but there are there's no solution for
the ailment and the
pain of hundreds of millions of women
who suffer daily from different uh
issues
and uh in the past i would say a year or
two we see the great i would say rise in
interest in what's called femtech female
technologies
uh this field is booming we started
five years ago um but just in the past
year or two you suddenly see the you
know the
significant races uh the unicorns that
are that are uh
uh setting up shop as well
uh and suddenly the industry realized
that that realizes that uh leave aside
the comfort that those women deserve
that there is a huge opportunity here as
well
uh yo tom i have to to address this
because i you know this is why i do this
this show
and getting exposed to something that i
know very little about and i think that
you know i enjoy researching and i enjoy
getting to new companies and it troubles
me
that i know so little about female tech
and and i personally am inspired by by
the work that you're doing and your
openness about it and anything the
intentionality with which you come and
you understand saying this may be taboo
for the world but you know this is a
part of our
of our regular conversations it's an
important thing to be able to talk about
especially it's something we must talk
about given the the under the how
underserved this market is and uh and so
i'm personally and inspired by the fact
that you're dedicating your career right
now to to be addressing this and i'm
excited by the the idea that there is
now a rise and and boom in this and and
i think that you know what what i'm
curious about is
from your perspective
how how is the reception from those
around you from the people around you
for the on the in the business world are
people aligning to this understanding
that there is a
huge huge market for this that is
underserved
while it's also going to be making a
really really positive impact
i can tell you that it's changing but uh
we still have a long way to go and i
have to tackle two points here because
i'm dealing in two i would say uh
notorious uh subjects one is cannabis
and the other one is women's health
both subjects we see a lot of synergy
between those two because both subjects
have been neglected
um
by the by uh the public by the industry
by the regulators for many many years
um
they are both in their quite early
stages
and they are both quite a taboos each in
their respective field cannabis because
everything we know about it and women's
health because it's not so i would say
um
freely discussed you know as i mentioned
sex menstruation bleeding well until uh
two or three years ago we were we would
see
commercials for
menstrual products that mimic blood with
a blue color i mean it's ridiculous and
the fact is that that it's starting to
change we are
beginning to see
the
uh
the subject out there on the table
discussed
and uh there's there's no other way i
think that uh no
post me to era did its thing as well uh
and i think that just as we see uh the
women empowerment movements
in different uh arenas uh so when we
speak about their health this should be
as a top priority but um you know when
you're looking today
entrepreneurs
around the world
that are
you know considering where they what
what type of injury they want to be
doing and where they're going to be
addressing what what are some tips that
you can provide them so that they can
either
not be
not be taken aback by the taboo-ness of
the subject or even simply just expose
themselves to the subject because
obviously there's less materials about
this and there's less hype around this
right now and therefore you know with
the butterfly effect then there's less
as a cause there's
less people that are going to start
companies in this field
it's true but we definitely see the
change uh i can tell you that
just
two years ago 2019 there were
around
femtech companies globally uh i think
that uh now this number
uh is around the amount of companies in
israel uh dealing with femtech uh
but uh i would say in addition to that
that you know it took me a very long
time to be able to
uh
convince and
be able to present again as a
as a young male who's not a doctor and
honestly this is the case about
how am i the one speaking about women's
health and trying to
provide solutions to a problem of
hundreds of millions of women worldwide
but the point is that i think that
because we've i'd say uh took off the
table the taboos and are able to speak
about it freely without uh
without a slight uh laugh or you know a
wink
allows us to do it the right way truly
and we have here discussions i can tell
you that both with our team both with
potential uh you know our partners and
people who we are we are discussing with
uh many times uh it's it's
the first time that some of the our
let's say the ones on the other side of
the table are speaking about such
subjects in an open manner and without
any emotions behind it on one hand and
without any excitement or
i would say
shyness around it
and this is the way to do it i think
that in the end we need to
neglect and avoid all the different um
i would say
uh stigmas
and uh you know emotional aspects of
speaking about sexual matters
and menstruation and such and once we're
able to do that and speak in a direct
professional manner
then this is the only way i think to
really bring it to the front and to
you know
avoid
the the past
stigmas and
taboos surrounding such subjects
thank you very very much for this um
fascinating conversation i learned so
much
and
and i have i have my work cut out for me
for after this to do my own research
and uh but but for now thank you very
much for everything i really appreciate
your time your energy and and the
amazing work that you're doing here and
that is going to make it a very very
positive impact not just for females but
for knowledge and understanding around
the world
so your time thank you and stay safe and
stay healthy
[Music]